good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on skype for
the first time in 59 years the queen
will miss the state opening of
parliament because of her mobility
issues and prince charles will deliver
her speech instead some news this
morning about what will be in it
including new laws targeting protesters
but is the real story what won't be in
it with some back bench conservative mps
telling this program they want the
chancellor to do more to help tackle the
cost of living lots to put to the
policing minister kit malt house very
shortly and let's not forget that beer
with kia he's now put his future in the
hands of the police is that a calculated
gamble too far we'll ask labour's
bridget phillipson after eight o'clock
and david cameron's former advisor
that's alex dean it's tuesday the 10th
of may
new laws to be revealed in the queen's
speech but questions over how much help
is coming for the rising cost of living
with prince charles set to deliver it
the queen has pulled out of the state
opening of parliament for the first time
since 1963
the palace saying it's down to mobility
problems
beergate to feargate what next as
sakiyas dama puts his future as labour
leader in the hands of durham police
lighting up the sky the russian
fireworks to celebrate victory day
followed by a fresh missile strike
in southeast ukraine the u.s president
worried putin has no exit strategy
tragic news this morning no one knows
how long i've got left the podcaster
deborah james reveals she's been moved
to hospice at home care to treat
her terminal bowel cancer
after a week on the run an alabama
prison guard accused of helping a murder
suspect break out of jail dies following
a car crash with u.s marshals
the wagatha christie trial footballer's
wives rebecca vardy and colleen rooney
head to court for a libel trial where
they're live
summer blues delays and distress for
some passengers trying to get away for
their holidays we'll ask travel expert
claire oven what's going on at half past
nine
also coming up for you on the program
this morning wherever you're watching us
from dublin to dubai with even the
running stones
[Music]
as i was saying with even the rolling
stones struggling to shift tickets we'll
ask how the cost of living crisis is
hitting the gigs and festival markets
and who's that knocking on the door 9 45
we'll meet david leakey the former black
rod the man who used to organize the
queen's speech ceremonies to discuss why
this one is so different
[Music]
good morning everybody we begin with the
queen's speech which for the first time
in 59 years the monarch will miss
because of her mobility issues prince
charles will deliver it but questions
this morning around its substance and
how far it will go to tackle the rising
cost of living with a number of back
bench conservative mps telling this
programme they want the chancellor to do
more to help tackle the cost of living
what we do know is we're expecting new
laws to crack down on disruptive
protests there'll also be legislation to
scrap several eu laws questions still
remain though over whether the northern
ireland protocol will be referenced
under a so-called leveling up and
regeneration bill there'll be measures
to revive struggling tan centers by
giving councils more
power and boris johnson has promised the
speech will also include proposals to
address the cost of living crisis well
the policing minister representing the
government this morning kit maltos is
with us now it's always great to see
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning um
how is the queen's speech going to help
people who are struggling with the cost
of living minister
well you'll have to uh allow me to avoid
a reprimand by the speaker by not
previewing what's going to be in the
humble address as they say um
prince charles obviously will be
delivering it later so we don't have
long to wait but we are very focused on
some of the themes that you've been
talking about this morning first of all
obviously growing the economy as the
prime minister said i think yesterday
while we are putting significant
government spending behind assisting
people through this really challenging
period of of way of price inflation
we have to bear in mind that we can't
spend our way out of this problem we
have to grow the economy and so looking
toward growth will be key
the second theme i think you'll start to
see is about keeping our streets safe
obviously my primary job in life is to
make sure that you and everybody else in
the country can sleep safely at night
and go about their business
in safety too uh the third area we'll be
looking at uh funding the nhs uh covert
backlogs making sure that we can get
ahead of that
as well as
showing some of the benefits if you like
of of brexit um in the legislation
that's brought through it's worth just
saying okay as far as the the cost of
living crisis is concerned it is
incredibly challenging for people out
there at the moment obviously
legislation takes some time uh to put in
place it has to go through both houses
can often be many months sometimes over
a year before it hits the statute book
but i do know that the prime minister
the chancellor are in constant
conversation about how we can be agile
and assisting people through this
challenging time
um does that mean that we're potentially
we're looking at an emergency budget
well i don't know you'd have to get the
chancellor on and talk to him about
about that but i think he said in the
media yesterday that he is constantly
reviewing what he can do to assist now
we're obviously in a time of very
volatile fuel prices they are moving
around a lot
we need to see a little more i think he
said yesterday about where that fuel
price is going to go before we design uh
what may come forward
but we're very focused on trying to give
people as much help as we can as you
know we put 22 billion pounds now of
overall assistance into helping people
uh whether it's through their fuel bills
or through the the community hardship
fund now expanded to a billion pounds
focused on on the very um
those who are suffering the most in this
awful crisis but at the same time our
key objective is to get as many people
as possible into work and having a
thriving growing economy that provides
the employment they need using universal
credit to stimulate and help them into
work we think is the best solution for
families across the country
doesn't sound as though you're ruling it
out
well we don't rule anything in or
anything out i'm afraid you're asking
questions about my pay grade okay that's
well you're representing the government
this morning minister no no no i am but
as i say you have to get them on i do
know that they are looking very very
carefully almost every day at how people
are struggling with their
with their prices of food and fuel and
the choices that they're having to make
and i know that they're giving it
careful thought about what the next step
should be what are the prediction what's
your prediction for uh inflation by the
end of the year
well i i'm a government minister so i
can't make a personal prediction to you
but obviously we look uh right with
alarm at the predictions that the bank
of england have made uh just in the last
week or so of inflation peaking towards
the end of the the year and we'll have
to think carefully about what our
response to that might be obviously the
bank is taking the measures it needs to
do by raising interest rates to start to
restrict that money supply to kind of
dampen things down a little bit so that
inflation doesn't get out of control and
i sincerely hope that that works
how concerned are we that inflation
might get out of control i i recognize
the fact that you said alarmed as part
of your last answer
well obviously
any rise in inflation above what we've
been used to which is at or around the
two percent mark is is a cause for
concern the bank is indicating that
we'll peak and then fall away which we
all have to work towards that includes
them in monetary policy and the uh
chancellor and fiscal policy but look
okay in amongst the the inflationary
problems that we're experiencing at the
moment do we do have to focus on the
fact that the post-covert economy needs
to grow
and so stimulating capital to invest in
businesses
looking at how we can turn all those
brilliant ideas that come fizzing out of
the british people um on an almost daily
basis into businesses which could become
world-beating at the same time as making
sure that as many people as possible can
access high-wage high-skill jobs giving
them the tools they need through
training and skills uh which nadeem is
doing with great aplomb so that they can
access those jobs too that's about our
future economy and that's where we need
to go
um i note with interest a couple of
years ago we were just looking at that
in the office this morning about august
2020 the
prime minister said there will be no
border down the irish sea over my dead
body is what he said
that's exactly what we've got isn't it
so what's the government going to do
about it
so we're obviously in close discussion
with the eu about the operation of the
northern ireland protocol i think it's
worth remembering um that as we reached
uh the the late stage of 2019 the house
of commons had effectively pulled the
rug from under the prime minister by
taking no deal off the
table and that meant that we went into
the brexit deal if you like the the
arrangements to leave
in the hope that everybody would be
flexible um around the northern ireland
protocol sadly we haven't seen that very
legalistic approach uh from the eu but i
know that the foreign secretary is in
constant conversation with the eu
and their negotiator about how we can
make that protocol
work for the whole of of northern
ireland obviously there is great
distress on the union side i don't think
there's any party that went into the
recent elections not asking for change
in the operation of the protocol i think
that needs to be recognized by the eu
and hopefully we'll see some flexibility
in the months to come
and does flexibility also potentially
include scrapping it
well look i can't predict what's going
to happen again that's a matter for the
foreign secretary but obviously article
16 uh that sits in the product is there
for a reason um
but i know that what we
fervently want to do is to reinforce the
belfast agreement the good friday
agreement uh maintain the um
if you like the settlement in in ireland
as a whole um but make sure that people
in northern ireland feel that their
rights as part of the united kingdom are
being respected um and prioritized and i
know that the foreign secretary will be
looking at that very seriously over the
weeks to come yeah but the majority in
northern ireland voted for parties
supporting the northern ireland protocol
so it would be inappropriate um to
scrap it wouldn't it
i don't think that's right kay i think
all parties uh who are standing in the
election uh wanted changes in the
operation of the protocol
um and obviously i think most votes went
uh to a variety of parties who supported
a unionist
position so you know we need to bear in
mind that we've got twin objectives
really first of all the northern ireland
is part of the united kingdom and that
integrity of the united kingdom has to
be preserved but we also want to honor
our commitment to the good friday
agreement
we think we can do that with some
flexibility around the operation of the
protocol and i
i know that the foreign secretary will
be talking to the eu chief negotiator
intensively over the weeks to come
particularly as we try and get that
executive back up and running um to try
and achieve that um is the prime
minister going to be directly involved
in brokering um a deal for the uh power
sharing fixing the power sharing in
northern ireland because it's a mess
uh well look in the past as you know
prime ministers have taken a a leading
role in in northern ireland negotiations
i would imagine he's done the same he
did as much if you remember in the
negotiations with the irish government
leading up to uh brexit so he he stays
very close to his northern ireland
secretary and i know that they talk a
lot about the negotiations and if
required i'm sure he he will
is it going to need the prime minister
to get involved because it is as i said
a mess at the moment what is the time
frame for trying to fix it
well we obviously want to fix it as soon
as possible because it's clear that
business in northern ireland
particularly is is not uh doing well out
of the protocol um and that needs to to
change and i know the foreign secretary
is as to say in intensive conversations
as is the northern ireland secretary and
the prime minister will be as involved
as he needs to be to try and deal with
any deadlock should it arise it's a very
delicate situation at the moment we
recognize that um and it requires
everybody to get around the table and to
to be flexible if you like in their
approach to make sure that we preserve
that settlement that agreed settlement
through the good friday agreement in
northern ireland um is that a direct
appeal to the dep
not necessarily no i'm just saying we're
i'm being realistic about the situation
in which we we find ourselves um
as i say we we want to engage with the
eu with the irish government with the
dup to make sure that we reach an
arrangement that is satisfactory to
everybody
okay let's talk about uh
beer with care should we uh we we heard
uh from keios diamond saying i believe
in honor integrity and the principle
that those who make the laws
should follow them
um that's a direct dig at the prime
minister isn't it
possibly i don't know you'd have to ask
him look i i'm staying out of this one
as policing minister it would be
inappropriate for me and unwise to
comment on a situation where there's an
ongoing police investigation um i
haven't in in other situations that have
been similar and i certainly won't uh in
this i've never been i have to say
particularly sensorious about other mp's
conduct uh how he conducts himself as a
matter for kirsten
if he's fine should he resign
again you'd have to ask him
um
that's down to him he set his own
parameters for operation uh in the past
as i say i've never been sensorious
about the way other mps conduct
themselves try not to give advice to
other people
other elected politicians other than to
say it's unwise for anybody to comment
on an ongoing police investigation he
says he's going to go he says if if he's
fined he will have to go he feels that
that would be the appropriate thing to
do as a result however you know you can
dodge it if you like but the prime
minister will also have to go if the
leader of the opposition resigns for the
same thing
well i'm not sure that's the case okay
but you're trying to draw me into
something that i really don't want to be
drawn and you have to recognize that as
policing minister i really should not
comment on a situation where there's an
ongoing police investigation we need to
leave the police space and time to do
their job with their usual commitment
and exact issues and i'm sure in this
situation they will do as they have in
others well given that your policing
minister how much pressure do you think
uh durham police are on denial
well you know durham police will operate
professionally uh to the high standards
that we expect of them uh irrespective
of what the
external goings-on are around this case
but as i say we need to leave them the
space and time to do that job i'm sure
they will and they'll reach their
conclusion in due course um i didn't
okay if you wanted to cover some of the
public order stuff that we've got out
today okay i'm happy to talk about what
i'd like to talk about if that's okay
minister oh
thank you as far as durham police are
concerned
if
we do find that they there's a case to
answer against kiyostama without
question they are going to have to find
themselves in something of a pickle
unless they again look at dominic
cummings and what happened in april of
2020 aren't they as policing minister
well kate as policing minister i need to
be very careful
uh that i'm not
seen to be influencing who the police do
and don't pursue
that is not my job my job is to set the
priorities nationally for the police and
that includes looking at murder serious
violence rape and sexual assault
neighborhood crime like burglary robbery
car crime which are happily down quite
significantly now um and so i i very
much i do the what i certainly don't do
the how and i would not dare to step
across the line and talk about specific
individuals no but would it not be
reasonable to assume that if there were
if there was um a high profile case that
was being looked at where someone was
found guilty of breaking the law of the
land and there was a similar breaking of
the law of the land potentially then you
would expect our police service that uh
you um our minister for at the moment to
look into at least consider that
look as i say i i'm not okay you're
going to trying to draw me into making a
comment on ongoing investigations or
prospective investigations i really
don't want to i know it would be
reasonable to expect that minister well
i i really i know twitter's going to go
mad that i'm avoiding the question but i
really do have to respect uh the
operational independence of the police
and allow them space and time to do
their job as they see fit that is what
we vest in them that is what we trust
them to do i trust them to do things
professionally every single day and i
really don't want to get into into that
debate if you don't mind i i understand
it's a public interest but particularly
in my position as policing minister it
just wouldn't be proper i'm afraid but
you do acknowledge it is of public
interest
well obviously the whole situation is of
public interest it's certainly of
interest to
the news media but as i say i i really
can't comment
okay good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time to join us on the
program this morning thank you
started off our conversation uh talking
about the queen's speech and we'll be
talking about that in more detail in
just a moment before that though let's
have a look at what the papers are
saying
um the telegraph leading with the news
the queen is to miss today's state
opening of parliament because of her
mobility problems and that her speech
will be read by prince charles instead
same story for the sun with the headline
crown and out the times leads on the
labour leader gambling his career on
being cleared by the police
investigation into beergate they go see
it is a public interest as the mirror
puts it this is what honor looks like mr
johnson there you go
uh while the guardian saying describing
it as stammers gamble adding labour says
they have compiled a dossier of evidence
proving the curry and beers were part of
a working day
queen's speech today in name sadly as we
will not be seeing her majesty rhiannon
standing by for us this morning hi uh
rhiannon it's it's not right to say
she's unwell but she does have mobility
issues
that's right and and i think it's
something that the royal family are
having to adjust to and we're also
having to adjust to and it means that
very late in the day we're finding out
whether or not she's able to attend
certain events but of course the state
opening of parliament is such a key part
of her constitutional role and while in
recent years we have been seeing that
really softly softly approach to
transition this there is no doubt is
going to be a defining moment for the
monarchy as we see her handing over
that responsibility of course there has
been a lot of discussion recently about
whether or not she was going to be able
to to attend this event or not but this
is a time where we're going to see a
number of firsts the first time that she
is handing over that responsibility the
first time another member of the royal
family is going to read that speech in
70 years the two previous occasions that
she missed it when she was pregnant it
was read by the lord chancellor the
first time that prince charles is going
to read that speech and the first time
that prince william is going to attend a
state opening of parliament
she herself has admitted that she has
been struggling to walk and it has meant
that she's pulled out of a number of
services where she would have had to
walk great distances so the likes of the
cobble wealth day service the maundy
service and of course the state opening
would have been pretty much the same and
while the palace and those inside
the palace of westminster would have
made every accommodation to try and get
her there i think they've decided that
really it was a step too far what's been
really interesting is speaking to
constitutional experts about it
yesterday they were intrigued to see
exactly how this was going to work they
didn't necessarily expect a letters
patent so that special rule change
to be enacted but they do say that in
terms of a historical perspective this
is us seeing our constitutional fl our
constitution flex and change to
accommodate for an aging monarch but i
think the palace wants to stress this is
an ageing monarch this is not an
abdicating monarch and yes she has today
realized that she does have to hand over
that responsibility but she is certainly
not stepping down
okay for now thanks so much indeed thank
you of course rhiannon talking us
through events um throughout the day
today here on sky news and we'll be
bringing you full coverage of the
queen's speech delivered by the prince
of wales that's from 10 30 this morning
and just a reminder that next week we'll
be taking the show on the road for a
special series of programs going back to
my roots and finding out how the good
people of wigan feel about the cost of
living crisis to let me know if you'd
like to get involved by sending me a
tweet use the hashtag
kbuddy
and that's going to be here on sky news
at the usual time from the 16th of may
all week
still to come on the program this
morning though as the fighting continues
in ukraine we'll speak to the former
head of the country's security service
now a member of the ukrainian parliament
what can we learn from president putin's
body language at russia's victory day
parade yesterday we'll speak to
psychologist judy james
labour's shadow education secretary
bridget phillips and joining us in the
studio just after eight
but before that joe biden says he's
worried that vladimir putin does not
have a way out of the war in ukraine
speaking at a political fundraiser the
u.s president said the russian leader
mistaking believed the conflict would
destabilize nato and the european union
it comes after president putin gave a
speech at russia's victory day
celebrations yesterday topped off with
fireworks over moscow the russian leader
used the event to justify the war in
ukraine claiming it was a preemptive
move to ward off aggression against
russia
meantime ukraine's military say one
person was killed five wounded after
seven missiles hit a shopping center in
the southern city of odessa overnight
emergency services fought the blaze
while trying to find any signs of life
in the wreckage of the building
ukraine's defense minister saying that
russian forces backed by tanks and
artillery have attempted to storm the
azer-style steel plant in mariopol the
last remaining pocket of ukrainian
forces having been holding out in soviet
era tunnels beneath the complex
while alex is in dinipra in central
ukraine for us this morning they're
still holding on but burley aren't they
in uh mariopol
yeah for those fighters inside the as of
style steel works it does not look very
good at all uh all of the civilians have
managed to get out now they went through
a humanitarian corridor over the last
few days they have arrived in the region
of zapposia and to the relative safety
of occup of ukrainian uh territory of
course traveling through
many checkpoints in russian
occupied territory but
a very heavy bombardment on that steel
works when you look at the satellite
images k
of what has become of that place you can
see
the destruction whole areas of it have
been obliterated it is being attacked
from the air with kind of bunker buster
bombs very heavy shelling as well rocket
fire and questions really about how long
those men and women in some cases can
hold out inside
we learned from a press conference that
they held a couple of days ago they
didn't give exact details of how many
were still trapped down there but they
are running out of all essential
supplies food water and of course
medicine now in the rest of the donbass
the fighting is also
escalating it's intensified in many
places it's very hard to read though in
which direction this war is going the
front lines seem to be fairly fluid
moving backwards and forwards in some
areas
the russians are making gains but they
are also being beaten back as well in
other areas so it's very hard to read
that at the moment i think the bigger
picture of all of this of which way the
war is going again it's extremely hard
to discern but there is certainly no
peace negotiation and at this moment
there is no end in sight okay alex and i
thank you thanks a lot
tragic news for your podcaster and
cancer campaigner deborah james friend
of the show has been moved to hospice at
home care to treat her terminal bowel
cancer
she told her 300 000 followers she
doesn't know how long i've got left the
broadcaster
developed cancer in 2016 but tweeted
last night that it is no longer being
actively treated
she posted this message to her instagram
page
the message i never wanted
to write we have tried everything but my
body simply isn't playing ball my active
care has stopped
and i am now moved to hospice at home
care with my incredible family all
around me and the focus is on making
sure i'm not in pain
and spending time with them
she goes on in over five years of
writing about how i thought it would be
my final christmas i wouldn't see my
40th birthday nor see my kids go to
secondary school i never envisaged
writing the one
where i would actually say goodbye
well despite deborah's current condition
she has continued to raise as much money
as possible for cancer
and health charities shingi standing by
for us such tragedy good morning
yes really sad news this k i think
deborah james is best known for you
me and the big c that podcast but she
became much more than a broadcaster she
spoke
so openly and so well about her
experiences of that incurable bowel
cancer and she raised so much money for
causes related to cancer from medical
research to to broader issues as well
and she's also i think
more importantly a mother as well she
has two children her son hugo who is 14
and her daughter eloise and in that
instagram post which you just read she
spoke about how now she wants to spend
time with her family look at this this
clip here of her and her son hugo
dancing when he was younger and a bit
older but she mentioned how she wants to
spend time dancing through this together
sunbathing and laughing at every
possible moment she has also continued
trying to fundraise and raise awareness
about cancer she's setting up the bowel
babe fund in partnership with cancer
research uk and that will be a way for
for them to raise money for clinical
trials and research into personalized
medicine so it's quite clear that she
wants her legacy to be that more people
can can raise money and raise awareness
about cancer
okay um thanks very much thank you
well here's an update of deborah's just
giving page and this is how much she has
raised in a little over 24 hours
666
000 pounds i'm sure if you wanted to
get involved she would be thrilled to
know that you are rooting for others
who are also
battling
this
bloody disease isn't it my goodness
two children
a prison officer has died after a week
on the run with a prisoner she's accused
of helping to escape the pair were
captured by police in indiana but the
guard died after apparently turning the
gun on herself here's greg milam
it ended like this in a field in
america's midwest the fugitive's car
showing the damage caused when
authorities deliberately crashed into it
to stop them and a 10-day hunt was over
casey white was serving 75 years and
facing the death penalty vicki white no
relation was a respected prison director
on the verge of retirement yet on april
the 29th she escorted him out of jail in
alabama she told colleagues she was
taking him for a mental health
evaluation but instead in a sheriff's
car fled
when police were tipped off about a man
resembling the six foot nine inch white
at a car wash the net was closing in the
pickup truck they'd been using was also
found abandoned
as they were about to be arrested vicky
white shot herself and later died in
hospital casey white is now back in
custody we got a dangerous man off the
street today
he is never going to see the lie today
again
and
you know that's a good thing for not
just our community but that's a good
thing for this country
vicki white's family said they were
stunned by her involvement but
authorities said it was clear this had
been planned for some time
her death means they may never fully
know the reasons why on what was meant
to be her last day at work she risked
everything for a man with such a
threatening and violent history greg
milam sky news los angeles
at home it's the showdown between two
footballers wives locked in verbal
combat the wagatha christie trial starts
today colleen rooney and rebecca verti
will face each other at the high court
mrs vardy the wife of the leicester
striker jamie vardy is suing wayne
rooney's wife for libel after she
accused mrs vardy of leaking false
stories about her private life to the
papers the case which first broke three
years ago is expected to last a week
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now a new report says
that there's now around a 50 50 chance
that the world will warm by more than
1.5 degrees celsius that threshold over
the next five years compared with
pre-industrial levels
meteorologists say that carbon dioxide
emissions reach the highest level ever
recorded last year and the next five
years are likely to be the hottest on
record
and five people including a member of
parliament have been killed in sri lanka
after violence following the resignation
of the prime minister
a number of other politicians homes have
been set on fire coming after weeks of
anti-government demonstrations over the
country's economic crisis
the bad seed singer nick cave has
confirmed that his son jethro lazenby
has died at the age of 31. the news
comes just seven years after the death
of his younger son arthur who fell off a
cliff after taking lsd
the uk could tonight crown its biggest
ever lottery winner the euro millions
jackpot has reached 184
million pounds to be able to afford a
big shot without you only 14 players
have won a jackpot of more than a
hundred million with the current record
holder an anonymous winner of 170
millions in october of 2019.
just to say i wouldn't say if it was me
but it is me there'll be an empty seat
here in the morning bad news to the
prime minister as a car has crashed into
a house owned by boris johnson which is
worth more than a million pounds my
goodness
uh that's the house in camberwell in
south london metropolitan police said
the driver suffered minor injuries but
didn't need hospital treatment and that
no offences have been identified
i could have done all sorts of gags i'm
not going to do instead i'm just going
to say here comes the weather quickly
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
uh southern britain turning out mostly
fine today after a cloudy damp start in
the south east but there'll be heavy
blustery showers elsewhere mild but
windy western parts have a scattering of
showers while southeastern england is
cloudy with a little drizzle raining
places
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
prince harry has taken part in a tv skit
promoting his new sustainable travel
campaign
you scored three stars three stars out
of what
100 100.
the duke of sussex took to give up your
day job took part in a pre-recorded skit
with actors rhys darby and dave fame he
was given a positive rating by new
zealand for turning off the tap while
brushing his teeth but had points
deducted for dropping litter on the
beach
coming up after the break a big ukraine
guest to bring you and we'll be talking
about putin's body language that come to
statute
[Music]
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast program here on sky news
this tuesday morning the prince of wales
will deliver the queen's speech today
for the first time in place of her
majesty who is unable to attend because
of mobility issues
the government is expected to unveil 38
new bills including plans to crack down
on disruptive protests at today's state
opening of parliament
and the labour leader sakia stammer has
pledged to offer his resignation if he's
issued a fixed penalty notice for
breaking covered rules
a government minister has told this
program that the prime minister and
chancellor are looking carefully at how
to ease cost of living pressures i asked
the policing minister kit malthouse
whether they're ruling out an emergency
budget
well we don't rule anything in or
anything out i'm afraid you're asking
questions above my pay grade okay uh
that's well you're representing the
government this morning minister no no
no i am but as i say you have to get
them on i do know that they are looking
very very carefully almost every day at
how people are struggling with their
with their prices of food and fuel and
the choices that they're having to make
and i know that they're giving it
careful thought about what the next step
should be
like getting blood out of a stone this
morning alley good morning good morning
yeah he wasn't very keen to answer
questions on a range of topics including
um policing for which he is a minister
but um but it was interesting i think
hearing him talk about the cost of
living because i think that is going to
be the big focus today we've got the
queen's speech this is a massive moment
the state opening of parliament where
the government sort of set their agenda
for the next year obviously particularly
important because we had those pretty
dire local election results for the
government last week they're going to
want to woo voters have policies um that
show that they are trying to chime with
voters that they're trying to help
people but i think the big question
today is going to be not what's in this
queen's speech but what isn't and even
though we expect the prime minister to
talk about the cost of living and the
importance of growing the economy it's
not clear yet that there are going to be
any sort of concrete solutions for how
to deal with that and certainly
backbench tories i'm speaking to feel
like the government haven't gone far
enough and they want them to go further
before the autumn we heard i thought it
was interesting kit mart house not
ruling out an emergency budget that's
what labour been calling for he says
that rishi sunak and the prime minister
talking that they need to remain agile
he said we have to grow the economy we
can't spend our way out of this problem
that of course goes to the heart of this
you know how do you balance soaring
inflation and growth we're saying you
know this is a third session of this
parliament next time around the general
election will be coming into view so
it's a really important moment okay okay
ali ali's take at nine o'clock looking
forward to it uh the queen's speech will
of course be here on sky news later on
this morning so do stay tuned for more
on that yesterday morning of course we
were reflecting on victory day in moscow
in red square particularly with
president putin who made a speech um how
did that go down with others join now by
a member of the ukrainian parliament the
former head of ukraine's security
service and that is valentin
lali-vaichenko hello to you thank you
for joining us on the program this
morning what did you make of president
putin's speech
yesterday good morning
actually yesterday we call it in ukraine
we saw again the victory day madness in
moscow
and same day in ukraine in city of
odessa city of mikala russian troops
shelled our cities our civilians
using war missiles against us against
our cities this is the difference how
the v-day victory day
yesterday were spent in moscow and and
in kiev or other cities in ukraine so in
uh russian president's speech we did not
hear any any news any good news for
everybody for us for the whole world
it's still the same soviet kind
propaganda of uh let's say conducting
a world
on our soil because of this russians
motherland it sounds really like a
madness especially
on
v-day on victory day plus what we didn't
hear from
putin
a single word about casualties single
word about atrocities
uh his troops are being committed uh all
around ukraine where they are occupying
or trying to assault
us uh our troops our civilians uh all
around ukraine
on the contrary um president putin says
it's ukraine's fault for using civilians
as human shields
how we can use civilians as a shield
when from the russian black sea fleet
from russian caspian
sea fleet they are shelling
missiles caliber and others uh against
civilians there is no protection so far
ukraine
has to protect
our civilians that's what we would like
to organize together with our
international partners with the great
britain with the united states of
america and other countries to protect
our airspace to protect our civilians of
russian missiles plus
russians artillery are still pounding
civilian areas civilian cities almost
every day and every night this is how
it's going on here in ukraine at this
war
okay talk to me about the morale of the
people of ukraine um this war
has been going on for many weeks now it
doesn't look as though it's going to end
anytime soon how much longer
can the people of ukraine
hang on to not knowing where the next
missile is going to land whether it's
going to be on their property or whether
even if they're hiding um as we saw in
mario paul underneath the uh theater
there what might happen
actually a little continuing until put
in himself in order to stop it this is
the only man in the in this world who
actually started this invasion this war
against ukraine and we understand every
night here in kiev in other cities that
we can uh
expect any any shelling any minute any
hour so my answer is that to stop this
war and stop shelling uh on our cities
this is
mr putin's responsibility and decision
you were
head of security service um of ukraine
2006 2010 then uh 2014 2015.
um
how do you feel about that would you
like to still be in that role given
what's happening at the moment are you
pleased to have taken a step back given
what's happened to your country
actually my efforts then were to bring
closer to nato standards and eu
standards ukrainian security service and
to organize counterintelligence to stop
this hostile activity of russian special
services in ukraine
uh unfortunately after the uh
revolution of dignity russia invaded
first the first time our eastern part of
ukraine so for me it's okay to be back
and to strengthen our country and cyber
security in in order to be closer to be
up to
nato standards to be
the country
which are capable which is capable and
eager to defend ourselves on a very high
security standards
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
so much for taking the time to join us
on the program thank you
well as we were saying vladimir putin
taking center stage yesterday at the
victory uh parade on victory day in
moscow
what about his body language what was
going on we know that he said as far as
his words were concerned he was telling
us that actually what he was trying to
do was defend russia and russians and
that's why they had this pre-emptive
strike against ukraine but what was he
saying with his body let's find out with
body language expert judy james hi judy
it's good to see you
hello kay you too hi um what did you
make of what we saw um i noticed that he
was when he was seated he had a heavy
blanket over his knees what did we make
of that
this is interesting i mean we need to be
studying this man for two sets of traits
there's the physical health the physical
strength of the man but also the
emotional state and i i found this pose
particularly intriguing because he was
photographed and seen apparently sitting
i mean if you look at his body language
here he looks most similar to the
elderly woman sitting next to him you
know he's actually adopted a mirrored
pose to her and he appears to have a
blanket over his lap the only thing that
i would say and it would be very unusual
for putin to make this kind of a mistake
i don't actually think that was a
blanket if you look at the uh generals
next to him i think they were issued
with rain max and i actually think that
being the kind of alpha that he is he
probably thought that he would look
tougher by leaving his off rather than
putting it on but in actual fact what he
ended up doing was looking
like an incredibly
beleaguered
leader sitting there who needed a warm
blanket over his knees it vanished quite
quickly i think possibly somebody had a
quick word with him that it didn't fit
with this
tough guy alpha profile that he likes to
project but his body language even so
there okay we can see it's de-energized
forget the blanket you know the
shoulders are slumped
the feet are together he's normally very
splayed and the head is slightly
disappearing into the shoulders so in
terms of physical and emotional
traits he's making himself look very
weak here
what about well he did get up afterwards
dunning he had it what appeared to be a
quite a long walk as he went down
to the tomb of the unknown soldier to
lay a wreath there what did you make of
that
yeah this is where we start looking at
what potentially might be
the physical health yes he does have a
puffy left side to his face his walk has
very recently been
unsteady um
he has also got a trait and we can see
it here it's more pronounced of swinging
his left arm but keeping his right arm
down by his side that's something that
i've seen him doing for several years
now i remember about four years ago
being asked has he had a stroke so
that's not a recent development
um
his facial expressions and we can see it
here
he almost seems to be not able to
control particularly the right side of
his face there was a lot of sort of
pulling
when he was standing and sitting and
watching
it's as though several emotions were
going through the right side so the left
side is puffy the right side seems to
have a lot of muscle contraction going
on
yeah and and
let's feature his face a little more
should we he did look a bit puffy i
thought
yeah um
it is the left side of the face for some
reason or other
the thing that worries me kay and and i
know that you know as an alpha he looks
very beleaguered he looks very unwell
i'm slightly
wary of the fact that he reminds me a
little bit you know that firework that
you light on fire at night and it
doesn't go off that damp square and
somebody has to go out there and kind of
nudge it with their toe and it suddenly
explodes
there's something about his body
language that implies that
don't nudge this yet with your toe you
know he might be looking ill but when he
went to make his speech
we suddenly saw him
and getting back he changed his state
considerably when he stood on stage he
went from being this man who was
slightly unsteady with his head down he
suddenly looked up he looked straight
into the camera
and that's when it me because when an
alpha is beleaguered when an alpha is
showing weakness it can often be
its deadliest and that's when we saw
this kind of shoulder shuffle that he
started to do before he spoke it was so
he was re-energizing
um he kept rocking from one foot to the
other not in not in a fragile way but as
though he was rebooting strength and
that's when i started studying the
closer
facial expressions and that's when we
went from this slightly
weak look suddenly the the lips started
to tighten we saw a raising of the
muscle just under the eye
the top lip in particular started to
tighten he started to chew his words as
he was speaking and that's where we
could see a rebooting from this slightly
pathetic body language to somebody that
is fizzing with anger there was a lot of
anger signals particularly when he was
talking about what he believes the west
has done to russia so
you know it's a case of maybe don't poke
it with your toe yet the anger is there
and that can be when somebody's at their
most dangerous when they feel weak when
they feel threatened and they respond
with anger
okay judy that's fascinating stuff as
always so glad you could find the time
to join us thank you
and staying with you crane all creatures
great and small can be heroes especially
our four-legged friends patron the jack
russell was given a heroism award by
president zielenski
yesterday a patron has detected more
than 200 explosives since the war in
ukraine began he was busy wagging his
tail and barking away and he picked up
an award from as i said the ukrainian uh
president and canada's president justin
trudeau was uh also there as you can see
at the ceremony
some of my favorite things all in one
shot there
uh meantime what's happening as far as
uh kia stammer is concerned he's
properly doubled down hasn't he on what
might happen as far as beer gate is
concerned aiza aisha hazarika who
previously worked as an advisor to both
harriet harman and also the former
labour leader ed miliband is with us now
it's great to see you aisha thanks for
joining us on the programme
um this is quite a risk isn't it
it is um high risk um and i think a lot
of people even within the labour party
have been quite surprised that that he's
done this
and he's really putting his career on
the line he's putting his political
ambitions on the line look i don't know
if this gamble will pay off but i do
think in this day and age when we're
seeing a lot of political leaders
literally do anything to get themselves
off the hook and and save their skin
through other people under the bus
not take responsibility for their
actions i think it is quite unusual to
see somebody say no i will take
responsibility if i am found to have
done wrong i will fall on my sword we
don't see that very often in this day
and age in politics
and it's a big gamble it could pay off
or it could be absolutely catastrophic
for him yeah but what it is doing is
putting pressure on the prime minister
isn't it
yeah and i think there's there's a point
of principle he's sold himself as a man
of integrity his character is very
important he uses that as a defining
point between him and boris johnson but
you're right there is also a political
calculation first there's a media
handling calculation a journalist would
be asking this question non-stop i had
shadow ministers on my own show and of
course it's the obvious question to ask
if he gets a fixed penalty notice will
he resign that seems obvious so there's
a sort of strategic um sort of goal of
doing this but also what the
conservatives have been trying to do is
to sort of drag him down to be on the
same level as boris johnson to create a
false equivalent so if boris johnson
does get more party fines they can say
well look they're all the the same
aren't they they've got these fines
they're clinging on they're not
resigning let's just move on and i think
he's been very very clear from a sort of
very political point of view he does not
want that to happen because he obviously
believes he will be exonerated he
obviously believes that there are more
fines coming down the track with boris
johnson and he wants to put this clear
red water if you like between him and
the prime minister particularly on
character and making the rules and
breaking the rules
yeah but they should have come clean
earlier shouldn't they aisha you know
it was drip drip drip if you were
advising uh like you did previously with
uh miliband and also harry harmon what
would you have been telling them
well look it's it's very easy to be a
kind of an armchair general from the
sidelines these situations are very
difficult what i do agree with is i
think they could have got to this
decision a bit faster i think when the
the news came out on friday that the the
police were going to be investigating
this we did have this weekend of a lot
of uncertainty and it was a pretty
torrid time for shadow ministers who
were out on the airwaves and getting a
really really tough time on this
question and they had obviously been
briefed to say look he he's he's not
resilient we're not going to address the
question of whether or not he resigns if
there is a fixed penalty notice and that
did create a sense of sort of shiftiness
over the weekend but i think he's
eventually got to the the right place
now go back to the first point i made
in this day and age it is very very
unusual to see somebody a senior
political leader we've had boris johnson
you know say doesn't matter if i lie
he's got these 16 parties being
investigated he's got sue gray he's got
the privileges committee it is quite i
suppose refreshing to see someone say do
you know what if i've got it wrong i
will go and remember he really wants to
be leader of the labour party he fought
very hard to get this job okay aisha
it's great to talk to you thanks very
much for joining us
thanks
just want to show you this picture that
josh has picked out for is in the paper
of color the times pictures one of the
guardsmen passed out on the floor while
rehearsing trooping the colour ahead of
the queen's uh jubilee my goodness me uh
poor chap um i think it's chap
more on that anna queen speech coming up
in just a minute
[Music]